hey reject nation Greg Alba here this is
movie man mark with us today you have to
say it this is movie man or not the
whole sentence just the name this is are
we on your channel right now no okay
movie man mark that's exactly what I'm
alright I keep the guests happy go check
out his YouTube channel people a lot of
fun comedic hijinks you don't have over
there you don't have to but wow it's
your chance not worth listen hate your
vlog right now
you know youtubers do that over there we
have full-length TV show reactions
weekly Q&A is a bunch of goodies but one
of our main reward tiers whatever video
you requested must definitely do whether
it be a discussion some type of topic
video it's usually a reaction and today
comes from a man named Gregory Bullock
I'm sure he wants John in the video he's
actually driving two hours away right
now to go get a passport so instead you
got to settle for movie man mark Gregory
Bullock he lives all the way in Boston
sorry buddy sorry sorry that you're not
John or sorry you live in Boston I don't
live in Boston so sorry that I'm not
John it happens Gregory Bullock he said
specifically he wants a what culture
video we did a Google hangout with this
guy recently and Gregory I just got to
tell you other than the fact that you
have a sexy name I also think that you
really uplift my spirit when we make you
smile it makes me feel happy internally
when you're not in my sight I'm
depressed right away and that's what
life's all about you know having
emotions based on the people around you
he's basically saying that Greg you're
making Greg's life better only when
you're around I guess what I'm trying to
tell you is I'm codependent on you which
is ok yeah I mean he does pay you money
monthly right yeah he pledges to the
patreon yeah yeah I keep doing that
because I'm codependent yeah my paypal
links gonna be in the description yeah
we feel like just giving money out to
everyone let's transition [ __ ] we're
gonna watch a video from what culture
today he's got an SD card stuck to his
arm not anymore
eight obscure movie secrets it took
years to discover just put your
headphones on mark you're making it take
way too long across just years to
discover I can't wait for that
[Music]
not common if there's one thing that you
need to know about me besides the fact
that I am incredibly smoked is the fact
that I love X it's probably why I ended
up looking like one in later life but
it's also why I absolutely love Easter
eggs in movies and I'm not talking about
the ones that you can see coming a mile
off I'm talking about the ones that
taking years to discover do you've seen
where I'm going with this
yes that's right it's time for a list on
Easter eggs that to stir well years to
discover with this in mind I'm Jules
what cultures not comment these are
eight obscure movie secrets that took
years to discover but the care begin
don't forget to subscribe to stay
notified for even seen there Karthik
yeah exactly button gremlins lady thinks
that a classic film like gremlins would
have a poster that everyone would
basically have looked at so often and so
in depth at maybe no secrets left to
find at all well you be read because it
sounds out those one right under our
noses really as it is more a case under
our belts now admittedly this does take
some finding because of its tiny size
but if you look closely at the crotch of
the unseen figure holding gizmo in his
box then you'll see that the button is
the iconic Amblin symbol and a nod to
executive oh no its anniversary that it
got noticed my own package then rule
number seven hidden people have said
that Disney have tried to smuggle a lot
of smut into their kids films saying
that you couldn't really move the
genitalia and Pinay in their flicks but
to be fair when you look at most of them
you have to question who was actually
submitting this and what they want to
see rather than what's on screen however
however the rescuers definitely did
include a bit of smut yes there's
definitely a bit of jazz to this film
ass thanks to some pranksters in the
animation department you can see a tiny
image of a topless lady in the
background of a chase scene where
noticed until 1999 when the film got its
second release on VHS but once it did
Disney was shot and they reek
three-point Wow Papi's and absolutely
they didn't even know one of the best
things about Pixar films besides the
fact that they allow me to feel a motion
for once in my husk of a life is the
fact that they have so many little
details that tie their films together
into a sort of shared universe the
Saban's colored objects that look like
certain furry monsters and in the case
of ratatouille it's the one thing that
you definitely don't want to see in
their food a cockroach yes a year ahead
of its debut in wall-e
the robots cockroach companion actually
turns up in Linguini's apartment for a
matter of seconds they can claim that
it's just any old cockroach Pixar
themselves said that it was one and the
same being which yeah that makes it
amazing right there I will talk about
lemons in the beginning of wall-e they
love doing that I really didn't need
that existential crisis before lunch
number five the dribbling t-rex the lost
world Jurassic Park student named for a
movie gets a lot of stickball lovely
being a Jurassic Park movie let's face
it that means but there is one kind of
saves it but being so tongue-in-cheek it
almost pokes through the other god damn
side so remember that bit where the
t-rex is loose in the suburban
neighborhood well as it approaches a
house that it wants to take a nibble on
its spots a basketball hoop and then
makes a weird dribbling motion with her
arm
ETS you see yeah stupid he's walking by
this strange hasn't be out that long but
to be fed this little detail lasted a
fair amount of time considering the
amount of effort that goes into combing
over these films by the MCU banner
antics I'm looking at the film relies on
a genius use of a time live by Doctor
Strange to divide Dormammu basically
becoming round hog day - I've come to
bargain in fact this was clearly a film
that the team were aware that they were
mirroring as the date that the doctor
had his life-changing car crash was on
February the 2nd aka where does it
rather day day number three picture they
say
now this one gistic aproblem that had to
be overcome on set but still it's a very
interesting story now Ronald Lacey okay
the most horrifying Nazi in the entire
known cinematic universe couldn't make
some shots towards the end of the film
and look Steven Spielberg had to think
quick and by that I meant it he just put
his coat and hat on the seat during a
car chase that he was meant to be in and
no one noticed for absolutely years it's
kind of so I still didn't notice until
the very last second I'll be aware that
Wade wears a show that's kind of similar
to the one that chunk wears into doing
he was not the first to pay homage to
this well
tubby little critter that honor went to
Dennis Nedry in Jurassic Park who seems
to have dressed exclusively in Goonies
inspired outfit until he ends up being
Dino Shawn the movies first act this
clever little Amash the story Steven
Spielberg worked and produced with Chris
Columbus there we go wasn't discovered
until 2017 almost 25 years later and
number one the medication hint Silence
of the Lambs Hannibal Lecter is not the
sort of man that you want to invite over
for let's say a tea party because a he's
incredibly creepy and B has a paan shot
for munching on man meat that only your
mum could rival there's my one per list
when the very opening it's clear while
he is in fact behind bars he is actually
very much in control and it's funny that
while we're all shocked at the line I
hated liver with some fava beans and a
nice Chianti I just sounds like I'm very
very camp anyway there was actually a
second meaning to this line it turns out
that it's actually Lecter trying to make
a medical joke in his prison he would
have been treated with mono amine
oxidase
Mao is to control his mental condition
but as any medical professional like
Lecter would know amongst the things you
can't eat or drink with them are liver
beans and why lectin was basically
confessing that he wasn't taking his
meds
who were Vika and then we have it those
Wed obscure movie secrets that took
years to discover let me know what you
thought about them down in the comment
section below and before you go maybe
you'd like to check out lists that I've
done on the gaming channel or this that
I've done on that film theory you can't
go wrong because they both include me
anyways always I've been Jules you've
been awesome and I'll speak to you soon
bye okay well yeah we know Pixar does
those Easter eggs oh yeah they do after
like most of them yeah and if you
noticed the preview for well it was a
preview the wall-e cricket was in
ratatouille before wall-e came out so at
the time even if you do see that Cricut
you have no idea like why it's there so
I guess that one probably is the most
accurate to the title that they're
giving this video because you don't know
that it's an easter egg until while he
comes out the next year they even did
that with cocoa like in cocoa there is a
character from Toy Story 4 that we don't
know yet yeah I don't know you just have
to look for the kids that are playing
with toys and that'll give you an idea
as to one of the new characters that
will be in Toy Story 4 interesting so
that could be on this list to Pixar does
that all the time oh that's like an
intense version I mean I thought this
was a great list because I hadn't heard
of any of these actually yeah sometimes
I watch these list videos I'm like oh
yeah yeah I know but like with the
gremlins one with the Amblin a symbol
paint on watch the Steven Spielberg on
the bottom that is how do you know - how
do you notice that it was this confirmed
exactly also how do you zoom in that
much like a look at that yeah that's
like those like spy movies like zoom in
and then they say which i think is so
unrealistic but apparently it
successfully did it here I'm thinking
someone that discovered this probably
was looking at a huge poster of gremlins
right yeah like maybe it was the type of
guy that puts up the movie posters at me
yes and was just super bored and
realized like that's the Amblin
entertainment logo for them to even know
the Amblin entertainment logo they have
to be a big movie fan of course but we
should check the gremlins poster maybe
the Emlyn entertainment logo is already
on the poster and then they noticed oh
it's there and there it's on this twice
cuz it might be at the bottom of the
poster as well I would think it is so
then with it being on the button it's on
the poster twice let's see here
yup it's on the bottom left
side and it's also on the button so even
if you just have a very good eye you
would notice huh they got the same
emblem twice that is crazy but I don't
know yes still yeah that's amazing they
would have to be on a very big poster
what's cool about this to me is you know
Spielberg we're just doing record player
of one and that whole movie being full
of Easter eggs yeah it's cool to know
that he was always a big fan Easter egg
yeah yeah because I like three of these
movies are Spielberg movies and there's
a three or four of these movies are
either produced or directed by Spielberg
yeah the rescuers man that one like
Disney has always had that reputation of
you know they talk about the Lion King
wine well you can make a whole video
just about all the Disney ones where
there's like hidden things in there yeah
or The Little Mermaid with the guy with
the erection or something that's that's
funny yeah and and then this one I never
heard the rescuers was my jamm growing
up that was hardly my favorite Disney
movie growing up wow I have a VHS of
this movie so you notice how there's two
Disney movies in this list with rats
you got the rescuers and is ratatouille
and they both star incidence label I
think not exactly they both start with
art and there that's why marks here
coincidences yeah
those let's find some more I do like
Jurassic Park the lost world wait I need
a play back this dribbling moment that
these talking about you still don't see
it
that is so weird do you think they're
reading too far into that no I thought
at first but seeing it a second time
it's not doing anything it's walk around
like this then the second it passes by
the basketball that just makes it seem
so much more stupid the animator had to
like consciously play over Hillary even
notice that cuz the Lighting's so dark
oh my gosh there's another coincidence
we had the gremlins poster with an
easter egg and then this was the knee so
Spielberg just has a lot of Easter eggs
yeah I mean that's why I was saying that
ready player one three or four of them
are Spielberg movies oh you did like
three of these movies are Spielberg
movies and there's a three or four of
these movies are either produced or
directed by Spielberg just like thinking
of the next thing you're gonna say I'm
not paying attention I would say
probably
I was looking at the ISO this moment
right here in Indiana Jones where they
put his coat there I'm surprised no one
noticed that you know I didn't even
notice that until the last second that
this scene was on screen I was looking
around at all the movement so is that
yeah that's what I mean - the spielberg
tends to shoot his shots a little bit a
wider frame where there's a lot of
movement going on so you could choose
what to pay attention to yeah and if
this isn't moving it's so easy to see
why no one probably caught that that's
how magicians work right you have the
movement going on here while the real
trick is down there and you don't notice
that wow it really is just there's
nobody they could really put a double in
there yes like a skew it we don't need
it another spill r12 with the Goonies
references I had something I would have
never caught on to it isn't the exact
same shirt I think it's just a Hawaiian
shirt but yeah it to me just was like a
regular wine right it is it's not even
the exact same shirt no it's different
colors yeah I think that one's a bit of
a stretch purple green no they're
different those are different different
shirts I don't know maybe it's a
reference so the final one they're
talking about Hannibal Lecter basically
confessing to take his meds because of
what he eats and stuff is contradictory
what he's allowed to eat when he's on
his meds but I'm like for all I know
that could have been forced to rewrite
it to me that's something they're
reaching pretty far and for that to be
number one I don't know oh is it going
from ten to one eight so one yeah so
that's the biggest yeah that's kind of
the smallest to me I'm like if that is a
big plot point sure if that's confirmed
cool but if this isn't confirmed I feel
like you know so many you can watch
medical shows I don't think that's a big
that better often so in accurate to how
medicine works I'm talking about like
you know Grey's Anatomy it's gross er
these shows that are never fully
accurate for all I know that could have
just been some thing where they're like
yeah who's really gonna care you know I
don't even think that they noticed
screen writers that seems really small
to me really yeah we all these lights on
let them watch you ever get noise
no either way this was a fun list and I
feel like I learned a lot it's so gonna
be the information I like you know I'm
painting on my movie buddies and I
started saying Zoo Jurassic Park if you
watched it kid he's like tripling the
basketball yeah the guy who knows things
that's probably the coolest honestly
that is the coolest because it's my
father yeah but I do wonder if Spielberg
knows all of these yeah that's true
ready player one he didn't even know
some of the stuff he's admitted like I
didn't have the visual effects yeah oh
really yeah there you go cuz it's just
impossible to notice like even if you're
directing a film you got all these
animators putting in small yeah those
that you don't even notice my don't even
know that's I'm thinking like maybe the
gerbiling Palardy bother you notice
there's a dinosaur in ready player one
no how funny would it be if he's
dribbling a basketball they're just
doing the hand motion walking by you
really like that Easter yeah that's the
best one all right guys well other a uh
term is obscure references that did you
guys know yes and that question right
you guys can subscribe to the reject
nation click that notification Bell
check us on patreon movie man mark
subscribe to his YouTube channel as soon
as you can't people I do so you should
too thank you for that glowing plug of
course